بعيدًا عن الخطوط الأمامية ،
ضابط الاستخبارات التقني ، ليس اسمه الحقيقي
يزيل
طائرة استطلاع روسية بدون طيار تم التقاطها بالكامل ،
فنحن أول صحفيون
يعرضون كيف تستخدم روسيا التكنولوجيا الغربية
لقتل القوات الأوكرانية.
ربما يكون أكثر خطورة
من الكاميرا ،
فإن متتبع الهاتف الخلوي الذي يقول إنه صنع
في الولايات المتحدة المحرك الذي صنع في اليابان
ووحدة التصوير الحراري على الكاميرا التي
يدعي أنها صنعت في فرنسا
بعد أن غزت روسيا
طائرات بدون طيار مثل هذه ، مما يشكل رعبًا في
ساحة المعركة و  تحدث ثورة في
طريقة خوض الحرب ، لكن المعركة
للسيطرة على المكونات
بداخلها تكاد تكون بنفس أهمية توريد
صواريخ ومدفعية جديدة
في الخطوط الأمامية يخشى الجنود الأوكرانيون
الطائرات الروسية بدون طيار ويحتفلون
ويشاركون
ما يسمونه الضربات الناجحة
لجيش كييف  يقول الذكاء أن
الكاميرات القوية للطائرة بدون طيار مع التصوير الحراري
والأشعة تحت الحمراء وتتبع الهاتف الخلوي
تجعلني  يسهل على
روسيا قتل الجنود الأوكرانيين
من طائرة بدون طيار أو طائرة بدون طيار تحدد
هدفًا أوكرانيًا ، يمكن أن يستغرق الأمر من ثلاث إلى أربع
دقائق بالنسبة للروس للانخراط
فيها ، لذا فإن المحرك الياباني للعدسة الفرنسية
أجزاء جي إس إم المصنوعة في الولايات المتحدة ، وما مكونات الدول الأخرى التي
تدخل
هنا  list maxime يقول إنها تشمل منذ فترة طويلة
النمسا ، ألمانيا ، تايوان ،
هولندا ،
وظيفته تتبع كل رقم تسلسلي ،
اكتشف من صنعها ، وأخبر الحلفاء
بمعرفة كيفية منع تقنيات الطائرات بدون طيار في روسيا من
الحصول على أيديهم ،
لكن إيقاف توريد هذه
المكونات التجارية غالبًا لن يفعل  كن سهلاً ،
قد يكون لدى روسيا مخزونات ضخمة ولديها
تاريخ طويل في التهرب من الضوابط ، حيث كان مكتب التحقيقات الفيدرالي
يتعقب شبكات الإمداد الروسية
منذ عام 2014 ويحاول إغلاقها ،
لذا إذا استطاعوا ، فسوف
يستمرون في محاولة تجنبها
وهذه مشكلة حقيقية لأنه في كثير من الأحيان  هذه
مقارنة بشرائها من قبل
الشركات الشرعية التي أعلن مسؤولو المخابرات الأوكرانية
عن
إحباطهم من أن حلفاءهم يستخدمون التكنولوجيا
ينتهي الأمر في أيدي روسيا
هو مؤشر على مدى قاتلة
وحاسمة
الطائرات بدون طيار الروسية